my name's Georgie Fleischer from
Australia and I look after mobile
innovations which basically we look to
how we use the mobile phone for
customers shopping whether it's in store
or at home so I developed the Woolworths
smart phone app a couple of years ago
that involved lets them do their
shopping and scans lists and scans
barcodes and they can shop online or
shopping store so make their shopping
easier basically my favorite moment
would have to be potentially the
workshop 36 where we basically walked
into a room where there was tools and we
could play and I'm like really I get a
glue gun I haven't played with glue gun
since was at school
and there was paper and woodwork and
everything and we got an assignment to
do and we had to basically create
something using light and creating a
team and the best thing about it was it
just went so fast and we got to use the
design thinking process as well without
realizing it so it's pretty cool come
here with a brain ready to explode and
be really open minded and prepared to
unlearn some things that you've had
traits built into you before so come
really open minded I think and also I
think appreciate others ideas and others
problems that they've got and listen and
potentially you can help and learn from
it
so I think the key thing is to be open
minded and just enjoy it because it just
goes too quick